elle était annoncée par météo france
mais la tempête xynthia surpris par sa
violence voyez maintenant ce reportage
réalisé la nuit dernière dans un autre
village vendéen au moment où l'eau a
pris au piège ses habitants encore sous
le choc
il raconte cette nuit de cauchemar
qu'ils ont vécu sandrine gadet et damien
raveleau 15h45 ce matin c'est la
première ronde des secours à l'aiguillon
sur mer
l'eau a tout envahi bouleversant les
repères les re sont des torrents les
jardins les maisons les garages tout est
inondé et les familles surprises dans
leur sommeil sont hagarde désorientés
personne ici meurette imaginer que les
forces conjuguées du vent de la mer et
de la rivière en crue provoque un tel
cataclysme
j'ai cru à un moment donné qu'il y avait
plus de toit qui avait de l'eau qui
tombait dans la maison de chars en
entendant le bruit de l'eau et je me
suis levé décembre le vent que j'ai vu
qu'il y avait ces cinq centimètres d'eau
partie et l'on rentré par les fenêtres
par les portes
j'ai monté très vite très vite très très
très très vite
en l'espace de quoi un quart d'heure
c'était incroyable on est sorti par la
fenêtre et on a nagé jusqu'à chez des
voisins
hélas tous les meubles flottaient on a
déposé les deux enfants sera sur un
canapé pour qu'il soit hors de l'eau et
nous on a attendu en fait que les
pompiers de l'animation l'a appelé les
pompiers sont venus chercher
on a eu très peur en fait je pense qu on
a eu peur de mourir en fait puisque il
à lunel à vélo qui rentrait dans la
bouche et tout cette nuit une centaine
de personnes ont pu être secourues dans
la matinée les interventions se
poursuivaient toujours
car si la mer c'est à présent retirés
des quartiers entiers sont submergés et
on déplore déjà de nombreuses victimes
au dessus des communes de la faute sur
mer et de l'aiguillon
trois hélicoptères ont été dépêchés pour
localiser les habitants réfugiés sur les
toits
le préfet a demandé des renforts aux
départements limitrophes
alors sur place non